لاول مره في تاريخ الصين
رئيسا لولايه ثالثه مدتها خمس سنوات
ادى اليمين الدستوريه بعد تصويت البرلمان
بالاجماع على انتخابه تاتي ياتي هذا
اليمين مع توترات كبيره وبعد يوم من اتهام
الرئيس الصيني لواشنطن بمحاوله تطبيق
الصين وقمعها حذر وزير خارجيته من ان
البلدين
يتجهان نحو تصادم حتمي خطر لا مثيل له
هكذا تصف الاستخبارات الوطنيه الامريكيه
بكين شبكه سي ان ان تقول ان مجتمع
الاستخبارات الامريكيه الان هو من يدفع
الى التصعيد تحاول الاستخبارات التاثير في
نظره الامريكيين للصين ومن هنا تتصاعد
التحذيرات من تيك توك بحسب سي ان بل وتم
حظر التطبيق عن الاجهزه الرسميه ومشروع
قانون قدمه 12 عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ من
الحزبين بدعوى ان التطبيق الذي يستخدمه
130 مليون امريكي على الاقل يستخدم يستخدم
في التجسس